[Musique]
je ne saurais vous dire combien de fois
nous avons gravi cette montagne
pas une ascension une descente sans que
nous ayons un problème
de lima la capitale du pérou et nous a
fallu deux jours soit un périple en
voiture de 1000 kilomètres pour
rejoindre la région de cages à marca au
nord d ambre
en octobre 94 des archéologues de
l'université de tokyo sont sur le point
de résoudre un cas suspect qui n'a que
trop duré
[Musique]
l'équipe est dirigée par le professeur
au nous qui surnommé le docteur
voici les objets en or qui sont à
l'origine de la polémique
on en impute la responsabilité aux
archéologues qui ont découvert ces
objets laissez moi vous raconter comment
cela a commencé
[Musique]
l'équipe de chercheurs se rend dans un
village perché à 2300 mètres d'altitude
dans la partie occidentale des andes sur
la côte pacifique
on peut voir la montagne le village
n'est plus très loin
et voici le village où tout a commencé
c'est le village de la conga de la
province de san pablo de la région de
cages à marca il compte 500 habitants
par d'électricité mais tout de même une
ligne téléphonique
au fond se trouve le site archéologique
où les objets en or ont été trouvés ceux
ci sont ramenés au village
les villageois ignorent qu'ils vont
rejoindre une des chambres occupées par
les chercheurs
[Musique]
depuis des mois ceux-ci loue des
chambres
les fouilles ont commencé il ya sept ans
elle dure en général de juillet à
octobre
cela correspond à la saison sèche au
pérou
les chercheurs se rassemblent pour le
déjeuner la petite dizaine de chercheurs
japonais a été rejointe par des
universitaires péruvien
on appelle ce site qu'une tour ou asie
cela signifie le château du condor à la
mort de l'archéologue péruvien qui
l'avait ainsi baptisé l'origine du nom a
sombré dans l'oubli
il est bien où des péruviens et les
allemands à s'intéresser aux fouilles
mais ils ne sont pas restés les fouilles
n'ont vraiment débuté qu avec les
chercheurs de tokyo une trentaine de
villageois travaillent sur le site
leur salaire de 400 yens par jour
revenus non négligeables pendant la
saison sèche les sections qui ont été
fouillés sont recouvertes une fois
étudié afin de ne pas être endommagées
pendant la saison des pluies creusé puis
recouvrir
c'est le lot quotidien des chercheurs
ce travail de titan a commencé en 1988
quand les travaux de fouilles ont débuté
du site on peut voir le village où
résident les chercheurs la conga
derrière à 3 km on voit d'une ville un
peu plus important
[Musique]
c'est la ville de san pablo 5000
habitants le centre de la province de
san pablo la conga n'est qu'un petit
district administré par samba blot au
début des fouilles les manifestants
venus de la ville travis la montagne on
peut lire sur leurs pancartes
sauvé compte 3 il y en a bien une
centaine à leur tête le maire dénonce
les fouilles et accusent l'équipe
japonaise de voler les objets d'une
grande valeur historique
certains villageois sont assez bêtes
pour penser que les étrangers des robes
les objets de valeur je ne partage pas
cette opinion savait qu'ils avaient tort
mais en tant que maire de la ville je me
devais d'endiguer une situation
explosive
on utilise des faux et en cuir pour
punir les voleurs de bétail
le groupe de surveillance composent le
noyau des manifestants selon le maire
les habitants de san pablo ne font pas
confiance à l'équipe japonaise
quelle est la raison de cette méfiance
non on n'avait rien contre eux
on est allé voir ce qu'ils avaient sorti
de terre on était curieux c'est tout on
ne voulait pas les intimider tout débute
avec des sacs contenant des morceaux de
poteries les sacs contiennent tout l'été
sont déterrées chaque jour chaque pièce
soigneusement lavés puis numérotées
selon une classification précise les
femmes ne se charge de ce travail
au tout début des fouilles on amène les
morceaux de poterie à cage à marca
l'équipe passe le week-end à cajamarca
en portant des sacs remplis de tessons
de beauté cela attire l'attention et la
sphère s'envenime
[Musique]
on raconte qu'il rôle d'un psy les
objets de valeur
[Musique]
sans même vérifier si la rumeur est
fondée
le maire fait une démonstration de son
autorité ils accusent les archéologues
beaucoup ici non aux oubliés ni la
seconde guerre mondiale dont ni les
bombes atomiques
puis il s'est complètement emballé il a
dit que le village allait connaître la
guerre ou en tout cas quelque chose de
terrible il a même conseillé aux
japonais de partir sur le champ
on n'avait rien à reprocher aux
archéologues
on n'a jamais mis en doute leur travail
les hommes politiques doivent parfois
prendre ouvertement position les
manifestants ne font que répondre à
l'appel du maire je ne savais pas où
l'on allait j'ai fait que suivre le
maire
cette année la prose a fung une
archéologue péruvienne prend part au
full aux as foulée rejoint l'équipe
chargée des fouilles
je voudrais vous présenter à rosas foule
souriez attendez que je réajuste mon
portable
désolé c'est trop tard
dans son discours aux a fung réfute les
arguments du maire j'étais effrayé
j'ai essayé de surmonter ma peur pendant
mon discours à la foule
j'ai fait comme si j'étais sûr de moi
alors qu en fait j'étais terrorisée
[Musique]
jeudi que les soupçons n'étaient pas
fondées que soupçonnait les japonais de
voler les trésors du contour ou asie
afin de les ramener chez eux étaient
pure sottise
je suis péruvienne
je ne permettrai jamais que cela arrive
dans son discours le docteur utilisent
d'autres arguments
il prétendait être un descendant de
samouraï
les villageois pouvaient saisir quelques
mots comme samurai il ignorait ce
qu'était exactement un samouraï
mais le docteur a expliqué que c'était
un ancien guerrier
nous avons la même tradition tient
samouraï donne sa parole il la tient
toujours
sinon il se fait hara kiri le public
connaissait ce moment tout en prononçant
le mot monsieur nous qui a animé le
geste tout le monde a murmuré les mots
samouraï hara kiri et l'atmosphère a
soudain changé
il n'était plus question de trésors
nationaux et s'intéresser à nous
cet épisode constitue un tournant les
manifestants et de chercheurs
parviennent à un accord
d'abord les objets ne doivent plus
sortir de san pablo le dr honos qui le
maire adolfo arribas plata ceux du
groupe de surveillance ont signé avec
leur index
la capitale de la province cajamarca
city est situé à 2700 mètres d'altitude
de la conga il faut trois heures en
voiture la ville où résident les
archéologues occupe une place importante
dans l'histoire du pérou
la main
cette station thermale est toujours
appelée la station thermale des incas
en 1532 atahualpa l'empereur inca il
séjournait au cours d'une audience
accordée à pizzaro l'empereur fut arrêté
et jeté en prison
la résidence de détention de l'empereur
est situé dans le centre-ville et peut
se visiter l'empereur était détenu au
fond de la cour dans l'entrée on peut
admirer le tableau d'un artiste local
camilo bouras
on y voit les espagnols attaquant
lagarde d'atahualpa cet événement marque
le déclin de l'empiré inca
l'empereur offrit de remplir sa cellule
d'or et d'argent si les espagnols
acceptait de le relâcher
illzach au promis que l'empereur serait
relâchée l'intérieur de la cellule se
visite
l'empereur rempli la cellule d'or et
d'argent
mais le serment ne fut pas tenu
[Musique]
toute cette histoire commence en 1989
quand les archéologues découvrent des
objets en or comme tout wazi est un
ancien site religieux bien plus ancien
que l'empiré inca
bien que le temple est sublime 1
transformation
il a gardé son aspect original il y a
huit cents ans la partie blanche
délimitent la zone des fouilles
[Musique]
cette statue en pierre devait se trouver
en haut du temple après restauration
c'est là qu'on ramène la stature le
sommet du temple forment un carré de 100
mètres de côté
un cimetière entouré la statue celle ci
était la gardienne des défunts c'est là
que se trouvait les monuments les plus
importants qu'en sur cet emplacement ils
ont construit un cimetière
ils ont dû creuser à deux mètres
cinquante de profondeur ils ont ainsi
découvert quatre corps qui reposait au
fond chacun d'eux était entourée
d'objets de valeurs telles que des
objets en or et des pierres précieuses
nous pensons qu'il s'agit là de quatre
tombes
les chercheurs sont là pour étudier la
structure du temple ils sont surpris de
trouver des tombes
[Musique]
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
des andes que l'on découvre des tombes
sur l'emplacement d'un temple la forme
en étrillé de cette carafe permet de
verser le liquide sans faire de bruit
[Musique]
ces perles en solidarité devait faire
partie d'un collier ouvert pendentif
[Musique]
voici un colis est fabriqué avec des
langoustes retrouve ses langoustes
uniquement en équateur soit à 1000
kilomètres du temple
[Musique]
et voici un plastron en or une sorte de
jaguar avec deux têtes d'hommes
[Musique]
cette couronne en or et donner de la
tête d'un animal rue de face à l'envers
et de profil
[Musique]
celle là est incrusté de 14 visage ces
objets sont la clé permettant de
comprendre la culture des andes à ses
débuts
ces objets sont les plus anciens jamais
trouvé au pérou ainsi que sur l'ensemble
du continent américain
[Musique]
deux chercheurs font part de leurs
découvertes aux autorités locales
la nouvelle se répand comme une traînée
de poudre
ma première réaction a été de regretter
d'avoir déterré ces objets il aurait dû
rester sous terre j'ai imaginé les
ennuis que cela nous attirerait
[Musique]
ma
du jour au lendemain countout wazi
devient célèbre
les villageois accourent sur le site on
prépare à la hâte une exposition les
gens viennent de san pablo et de cages à
marca ils font la queue pour voir
l'exposition
si on leur avait caché des objets il
aurait nourri des soupçons pensait que
nous en cachons une partie que nous
avions des robes et ceux qui avaient le
plus de valeur
il valait mieux qu'ils voient ce que
nous faisions l'exposition a permis de
couper court à la rumeur
les villageois nous servait en quelque
sorte de témoin
ils ont vu ce que nous faisions les
chercheurs essayé d'expliquer que les
objets n'appartiennent ni aux chercheurs
ni aux villageois la majorité des
villageois répondent qu'ils sont la
propriété du village et doivent y rester
nous pensons que les objets doivent
rester sur leur lieu d'origine
le site appartient au village
les objets trouvés doivent rester dans
le village
voilà que la fièvre de l'or gagne san
pablo l'année précédente
il a été décidé que les objets seront
remis à san pablo plutôt qu aux
villageois le mieux à faire est que san
pablo se charge de l'administration de
kun de roizy
[Musique]
les archéologues vont à san pablo
présenter l'exposition
plusieurs milliers de personnes la
visite et chacun de dire qui de la combe
gard san pablo de cages à marcq un vote
abriter les objets en or
[Musique]
l'attachée culturelle du pays arrive de
lima la capitale
le jour le patron du restaurant
surveille les trésors la nuit yasutaka
taux prend la relève
on exige une surveillance particulière
la valeur de ces objets en fait des
trésors nationaux
l'équipe veut les apporter à l'institut
du patrimoine de lima mais les
villageois s'y opposent farouchement
on discute avec les autorités de la
ville
les officiels du gouvernement central se
rendent sur place mais n'autorise pas le
transfert des objets à lima les objets
en or ont été découverts à mois
seulement avant le retour au pays des
chercheurs
si les objets ne vont pas à lima où
peut-on les emmener l'équipe peut-elle
abandonné les objets dans le village qui
serait assez compétent pour s'en occuper
immédiatement après la découverte la
police a offert de protéger les objets
je ne devrais pas le dire mais les
villageois nous ont mis en garde contre
la police les policiers sont armés si ça
leur prend de changer d'avis ils peuvent
très bien nous tirer dessus
les archéologues décide de demander aux
autorités de san pablo de conserver les
objets dans leur mairie
en ce qui concerne la responsabilité
légale
nous aurions pu demander l'intervention
de l'état mais si nous l'avions fait nos
relations avec les villageois auraient
pu en pâtit ces objets ne sont pas
essentiels à nos recherches
leur absence handicapera pas de telles
recherches sont souvent le travail d'une
vie entière il faut apprendre à être
patient ces objets sont le témoin d'une
civilisation vieille de 3000 ans nous
pouvons bien attendre un an ou deux
s'ils doivent rester enfermés dix ans et
bien soit
c'était notre état d'esprit d'alors le
jour du transfert des objets à semblable
au les villageois porte d boîte
recouverte du drapeau national et les
escorte jusqu'à la ville j étais on
aurait dit une procession religieuse
c'était comme si on escortaient des
reliques j'écris est bénie soit notre
village béni soit la conga benisoit coup
dur ouazine j'ai crié pendant tout le
trajet
[Musique]
le maire ayant promis que les objets
retournerai au village les villageois
donnent leur accord pour la porter en
ville
un contretemps de dernière minute sur
gîte à l'arrivée à la mairie les portes
des archives ont été refaites mais il
n'y a pas assez de jeu et les portes ne
ferment pas
on trouve finalement une pièce fermée
par une double porte
les archéologues rentrer chez eux
soulagé
de retour l'année suivante ils ont vent
d'une rumeur selon laquelle les précieux
objets en or sont revenus dans le
village
luigi secci se met aussitôt en route
pour le village comme chez les nets qui
va chimiste
je m'attendais ce que quelques objets
mans non pas que les gens soient
malhonnête mais les objets n'étaient pas
assez protégé sur la mairie c'était
prémunit contre les vols en faisant
garder les portes et en fermant à clé la
salle que nous n'étions pas rassuré il
faut dire qu'au village les gens vont et
viennent et sans fermer leurs portes
cela ne faisait qu'augmenter nos
craintes
la rumeur est fondée
les élections ont eu lieu et les objets
ont quitté san pablo le maire qui les
avait recueilli ayant perdu son siège
[Musique]
le nouveau maire inquiète les villageois
il pense qu'il ignore la valeur des
trésors
l'ancien maire aussi est inquiet s'il
arrivait malheur au trésor ils
pourraient être tenus responsables
à l'annoncé des résultats
les villageois sont venus pour me
demander de leur remettre les objets en
or afin d'empêcher le maire de les
disperser
j'ai tenu ma promesse et les l'aurait
remis heureusement les objets en or
rendu au village sont en parfait état
la tâche la plus difficile revient à
julio le secrétaire du village il y
avait un homme de ce hangar qui traînait
dans le village il voulait savoir où
étaient les trésors il a menacé les
villageois de tuer ceux qui gardaient
les trésors il s'est caché dans la
montagne mais ils ne savaient pas qu'ils
avaient les trésors
il savait seulement qu'ils étaient dans
le village
ou jude law cash est il donc les trésors
suivons le dans le bâtiment voisin la
chambre de julio de sa femme se trouve à
l'étagé
attention c'est assez raide
je vais vous dire où il était vous voyez
ces boîtes les boîtes en carton je
cachais les trésors à l'intérieur près
de mon lit il a fait cela sans attendre
de récompenses
le site de fouilles le plus important se
trouve à cajamarca vous j c qui est
aussi responsable des fouilles poubelles
les trous autour du site prouve qu'il a
été pillé
au 16ème siècle les conquistadors en
pillant les tombes les ont désacralisé
depuis le pillage de tombes est devenu
pratique courante dans la société
péruvienne
archéologues doivent être plus rapide
que les pillards
[Musique]
un archéologues péruviens exprime sa
surprise en apprenant qu'on a trouvé des
objets en or il est rare que les
archéologues et trouvent des objets en
or avant que les pillards ne s'en empare
durant les trois années de fouilles à
couteaux wazi pas une pièce n'a été volé
c'est étonnant étant donné que les
objets en or ont été trouvés
on organise sur le site une cérémonie
suivant en cela les conseils de
l'archéologue lui senida carriole
monsieur cateau pouvez vous allumez les
cigarettes les cigarettes sont offertes
aux défunts le sénat était inquiète pour
le site la cérémonie n'ayant pas pu
avoir lieu l'année précédente
l'alcool de sucre de canne est offert
aux morts les participants doivent aussi
les zones où quelques gouttes et qu'elle
fait partie de ceux qui sont nés ici
dans les angles nous commettons un
blasphème envers les morts je leur
demande donc pardon cela peut sembler
bizarre mais j'explique aux morts que
nos recherches servent à la science
[Musique]
que faire à présent des trésors
plusieurs assemblées ont lieu nous ne
voulions pas que les objets restent au
village c'était trop risqué
il aurait été facile de venir avec un
fusil et de les voler pas question donc
de les laisser là bas c'était aux
villageois de se rendre à l'évidence ce
n'était pas à nous de dire vous n'êtes
pas compétents
cela aurait pu les offenser les offenser
gravement ces gens là ont toujours été
méprisé
nous devions éviter que cela recommence
des troubles ont éclaté dans tout les
andes
on ne peut pas leur dire on ne peut pas
vous confier ces objets l'état va s'en
charger pour vous c'est le discours que
tiennent les autorités aux villageois
c'est partout la même chose des
villageois savent tout cela mais il
n'apprécie pas que quelqu'un de
l'extérieur leur dise il y avait un vrai
dilemme
j'espérais que les villageois finirait
par se dire qu'ils n'étaient pas
capables de garder les objets que les
gardes et n'était pas la meilleure
solution
nous répétions sans cesse que ces objets
étaient important non seulement pour le
village mais aussi pour le pays et même
pour le monde pour notre civilisation
les journaux nous ont relayés en disant
que ces pièces étaient uniques ont
répété aux villageois la même chose
chacun a réfléchi et est arrivé à la
conclusion que nous avions peut-être
raison ils savaient ce qu'il leur
restait à faire
[Musique]
il refuse de remettre les objets à
l'institut du patrimoine de l'huma mais
d'un autre côté ils ne veulent pas que
les trésors reste au village le docteur
emmett une suggestion organisons une
exposition au japon afin de récolter des
fonds
avec cet argent on construira un musée
au village qui abritera les objets
sa suggestion est acceptée à l'unanimité
beaucoup cependant restent sceptiques
j'ai cru qu'on ne reverrait jamais nos
trésors
quand on les a emmenés j'ai ressenti une
grande perte
vous savez avec le temps bien des choses
changent et les gens finissent par
oublier
je craignais de ne plus jamais les
revoir
j'avais peur que l'on nous ait trompé
les précieux objets quitte le village
le docteur elias au taquet cateau décide
d'avancer le calendrier
du lycée qui se retrouve seul
la suite est sans surprise l'assistant
du maire de san pablo arrive en trombe
escorté par la police ils m'ont demandé
où était parti monsieur nuque et s'il
avait emporté avec lui les objets de
valeur je n'ai pas eu beaucoup de temps
pour réfléchir mes collègues étaient
partis depuis une dizaine de minutes
la police aurait pu les rattraper j'ai
dit qu'ils aient fait partie depuis une
heure ils ont regardé leurs montres et
ont dit qu'ils allaient établir un
contact radio
à la mairie on nous avait dit que
l'équipe d'archéologues allait emporter
tous les objets découverts sur le site
de kourou asie sans autorisation
sans autorisation
ignorant ce qui est arrivé à leurs
collègues restés au village le docteur
elias ou cathy gâteau se présenter à un
carrefour
la police nous sommes de s'arrêter nous
ne nous attendions pas être interpellé à
cet endroit
je ne pensais pas que nous aurions des
problèmes quand la police nous a demandé
de nous arrêter j'ai compris que j'avais
sous-estimé la situation
[Musique]
le docteur montre la lettre pour
l'institut du patrimoine à lima que
l'équipe a écrite la nuit précédente
elle stipule que les objets de valeur
doivent rejoindre lima la police accepte
ce justificatif
mais insiste tout de même pour les
accompagner
il s'agit soit disant de les escorter
mais cela lui permet aussi de les
surveiller
durant tout le voyage vers cage à marca
l'officier de police ne dit pas un mot
arrivé à cajarc à un autre problème les
attend la responsable leur ordonne de
lui remettre les objets en or
journalistes sont là les chercheurs
doivent remettre les objets il faut
juste attendre que la chef de la police
revienne de déjeuner
le docteur se précipitent pour
téléphoner directement à l'institut du
patrimoine à lima
l'instabilité politique du pays
perturbent les télécommunications et
puis quelqu'un décrochera-t-il il joue
là sa dernière carte c'est un miracle
que quelqu'un ait décroché
j'ai parlé directement au ministre kim a
affirmé ne pas avoir donné l'ordre
d'amener les objets à cage à marca il a
promis d'appeler l'institut du
patrimoine a cage à marca et de leur
demander d'autoriser les archéologues a
amené les objets à lima je n'en revenais
pas
ils l'ont échappé belle les trésors de
kun tour ou asie y compris les objets en
or sont en chemin pour lima ils ne
reverront pas de sitôt leur région
natale ya les mots tombe bien ils vont
d'un monstre à l'état vont d'abord à
l'état vont ils ont rappelé
[Musique]
ok
ce week-end
[Musique]
m
après être resté un an à lima les
trésors de couteau oasis ont prêté au
japon
à partir de 1992 les archéologues
organise douze expositions à travers le
pays
les expositions accueille deux cent
mille visiteurs grâce aux fonds récoltés
le projet de construction du musée se
concrétise
en 1994 on commence à faire des copies
les spécialistes en métallurgie viennent
apporter leur aide
bien que ce ne soit que des répliques
on utilise de l'or
pour rester proches des originaux on
ajoute 10 % d'argent les originaux
portent des marques causés lors de leur
enfouissement même ses imperfections
sont reproduites
le matériel est très délicat si un
accident arrive il faut refondre tout le
métal il faut six mois à trois
spécialistes pour produire 8 magnifique
réplique
en 1994 alors que ses collègues
travaillent sur les copies le docteur se
rend à la conga le musée du village qui
me semblait qu'un rêve va devenir
réalité
une organisation est née afin de
promouvoir la culture l'association
culturelle de coups de bourre ou asie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
l'hymne de péruviens retenti au dessus
du chantier du musée
posez ici on trace au sol un carré qui
va être le centre d'une cérémonie
monsieur onu doit briser puis enterré
une bouteille d'alcool de cannes
non il disait qu'on ne reverrait jamais
les trésors
je leur ai dit qu'ils se trompaient tous
ils n'ont pas voulu me croire
ils disaient ces gens là nous ont volé
nos trésors
pour la construction du musée on a fait
appel à un architecte de cages à marca
d'une surface de 300 mètres carrés il
sera en béton et en acier
ce sera un bâtiment splendide qui
éblouira les villageois le budget global
s'élève à 20 millions de yens on compte
produire de l'électricité localement
même si la lumière naturelle sera le
plus souvent utilisés on n'installe pas
de système d'alarmé si le docteur
voulait des copies c'est qu'il aurait
été trop risqué d'exposer des originaux
[Musique]
ce que les archéologues ramène au
village en octobre 1994
c'est en fait une paire de kobe ainsi
que les origines la faire c'est réglé
sans effort ou le docteur at il puisé
l'énergie nécessaire à ce travail
je suis un amoureux des andes le paysage
les gens tout cela m'enchante
je voudrais donc faire quelque chose
pour cet endroit c'est par amour pour
cette région
si les gens du coin sont satisfaits de
mon travail
pourquoi ne pas faire quelque chose pour
eux
[Musique]
depuis 35 ans yoshio nous qui se
consacre à l'étude de la région des
andes
[Musique]
son épouse et de la deuxième génération
des japonais installés au pérou
le travail est loin d'être achevée il
faut expliquer aux villageois la raison
des copies à l'institut du patrimoine à
lima je vous conseille de conserver les
originaux en dehors du musée de façon à
ne tenter personne de mal intentionné
les villageois hésite encore ils ne sont
pas satisfaits des copines mais
craignent pour la sécurité des originaux
c'est dire que devons-nous faire garder
les trésors ici où les entreposer
ailleurs devons nous exposer les copies
ou les originaux que faire
les archéologues ouvre le musée avant
son inauguration afin de permettre aux
villageois de voir les copies
originaux et copies sont placés côte à
côte sans aucune indication
chacun essaye de distinguer les vrais
des faux
à
les habitants de sympa blot on vend de
cette avant-première et se rendre au
village
elles sont magnifiques les copies ont dû
demander bien du travail impossible de
distinguer les unes des autres
je pensais qu'il y aurait beaucoup de
différence entre les deux j'ai eu beau
les regarder pas moyen de les distinguer
[Musique]
comme promis le trésor en or sont
retournés au village villageois donnent
leur accord pour que les copies soit
seul exposé au musée
le jour de l'inauguration arrive enfin
le groupe de surveillance est arrivé
l'ancien maire de san pablo est
également présent
d'anciens collègues de l'équipe de
fouilles sont là
l'hélicoptère du président fujimori sur
le point d'atterrir
cette dernière nouvelle se répand et la
foule se presse sur la colline le
docteur accueille le président
[Musique]
six mois seulement après le début des
travaux bîmes de péruviens retentit à
nouveau
[Musique]
les archéologues font don du musée
village les officiels du village
président est au retour au pays des
trésors ce musée a vu le jour grâce à la
coopération entre le peuple péruvien et
nos amis japonais
je déclare le musée ouvert
[Musique]
le trésor de couteau roizy attire
aujourd'hui bien du monde
l'équipe des archéologues offert les
copies à l'association culturelle du
village
[Musique]
le ministre de la culture a autorisé les
villageois à vendre les objets des
fouilles
excepté sur un an
tout semble s'être arrangé le noeud de
l'afer est dénouée
les archéologues compte apaiser les
tensions
beaucoup de bruit pour rien mais tout se
finit bien
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard archéologues
reprenez les foules
il
[Musique]
obama
la terre des âmes
[Musique]
tha
m
[Musique]
du jour au lendemain couteau roizy
devient célèbre
les villageois accourent sur le site on
prépare à la hâte une exposition les
gens viennent de san pablo et de cages à
marca ils font la queue pour voir
l'exposition
si on leur avait caché les objets il
aurait nourri des soupçons pensait que
nous en cachons une partie que nous
avions des robes et ceux qui avaient le
plus de valeur
il valait mieux qu'ils voient ce que
nous faisions l'exposition a permis de
couper court à la rumeur
les villageois nous servait en quelque
sorte de témoin
ils ont vu ce que nous faisions les
chercheurs essayé d'expliquer que les
objets n'appartiennent ni aux chercheurs
ni aux villageois la majorité des
villageois répondent qu'ils sont la
propriété du village et doivent y rester
nous pensons que les objets doivent
rester sur leur lieu d'origine
le site appartient au village les objets
trouvés doivent rester dans le village
voilà que la fièvre de l'or gagne san
pablo l'année précédente
il a été décidé que les objets seront
remis à san pablo plutôt qu aux
villageois le mieux à faire est que san
pablo se charge de l'administration de
couteau roizy
[Musique]
les archéologues vont à san pablo
présenter l'exposition
plusieurs milliers de personnes la
visite et chacun de dire qui de la combe
gard san pablo de cages à marcq un vote
abriter les objets en or
[Musique]
l'attachée culturelle du pays arrive de
lima la capitale
le jour le patron du restaurant
surveille les trésors la nuit yasutaka
taux prend la relève
on exige une surveillance particulière
la valeur de ces objets en fait des
trésors nationaux
l'équipe veut les apporter à l'institut
du patrimoine de lima mais les
villageois s'y opposent farouchement
on discute avec les autorités de la
ville
les officiels du gouvernement central se
rendent sur place mais n'autorise pas le
transfert des objets à lima les objets
en or ont été découverts à mois
seulement avant le retour au pays des
chercheurs
si les objets ne vont pas à lima où
peut-on les emmener l'équipe peut-elle
abandonné les objets dans le village qui
serait assez compétent pour s'en occuper
immédiatement après la découverte la
police a offert de protéger les objets
je ne devrais pas le dire mais les
villageois nous ont mis en garde contre
la police les policiers sont armés si ça
leur prend de changer d'avis ils peuvent
très bien nous tirer dessus
les archéologues décide de demander aux
autorités de san pablo de conserver les
objets dans leur mairie
en ce qui concerne la responsabilité
légale
nous aurions pu demander l'intervention
de l'état mais si nous l'avions fait nos
relations avec l'idée la joie aurait pu
en pâtit ces objets ne sont pas
essentiels à nos recherches
leur absence handicapera pas de telles
recherches sont souvent le travail d'une
vie entière il faut apprendre à être
patient ces objets sont le témoin d'une
civilisation vieille de 3000 ans nous
pouvons bien attendre un an ou deux
s'ils doivent rester enfermés dix ans et
bien soit
c'était notre état d'esprit d'alors le
jour du transfert des objets assemble
pablo le village où apporte des boîtes
recouverte du drapeau national et les
escorte jusqu'à la ville j étais on
aurait dit une procession religieuse
c'était comme si on escortaient des
reliques
j'écris est bénie soit notre village
béni soit la conga benisoit couteau
roizy j'ai crié pendant tout le trajet
[Musique]
le maire ayant promis que les objets
retournerai au village les villageois
donnent leur accord pour la porter en
ville
un contretemps de dernière minute sur
gîte à l'arrivée à la mairie les portes
des archives ont été refaites mais il
n'y a pas assez de jeu et les portes ne
ferment pas
on trouve finalement une pièce fermée
par une double porte
les archéologues rentrer chez eux
soulagé
de retour l'année suivante ils ont vent
d'une rumeur selon laquelle les précieux
objets en or sont revenus dans le
village
lui dit c'est qui se met aussitôt en
route pour le village je travaille comme
celle qui va chimiste
je m'attendais ce que quelques objets
mans non pas que les gens soient
malhonnête mais les objets n'étaient pas
assez protégé bien sûr la mairie c'était
prémunit contre les vols en faisant
garder les portes et en fermant à clé la
salle et nous n'étions pas rassuré il
faut dire qu'au village les gens vont et
viennent et sans fermer leurs portes
cela ne faisait qu'augmenter nos
craintes
[Musique]
la rumeur est fondée
les élections ont eu lieu et les objets
ont quitté san pablo
le maire qui les avait recueilli ayant
perdu son siège le nouveau maire
inquiète les villageois il pense qu'il
ignore la valeur des trésors
l'ancien maire aussi est inquiet s'il
arrivait malheur au trésor ils
pourraient être tenus responsables
à l'annoncé des résultats
les villageois sont venus pour me
demander de leur remettre les objets en
or afin d'empêcher le maire de les
disperser
j'ai tenu ma promesse et les leur est
remis heureusement les objets en or
rendu au village sont en parfait état
et la tâche la plus difficile revient à
julio le secrétaire du village il y
avait un homme de ce hangar qui traînait
dans le village
il voulait savoir où étaient les trésors
il a menacé les villageois de tuer ceux
qui gardaient les trésors
il s'est caché dans la montagne mais ils
ne savaient pas qu'ils avaient les
trésors
il savait seulement qu'ils étaient dans
le village
ou julio cachait-il donc les trésors
suivons le dans le bâtiment voisin
la chambre de julio et de sa femme se
trouve à l'étagé
attention c'est assez raide
je vais vous dire où il était vous voyez
ces boîtes les boîtes en carton je
cachais les trésors à l'intérieur près
de mon lit il a fait cela sans attendre
de récompenses
le site de fouilles le plus important se
trouve à cajamarca bougies c'est qui est
aussi responsable des fouilles coudène
les trous autour du site prouve qu'il a
été pillé
au 16ème siècle les conquistadors en
pillant les tombes les ont désacralisé
depuis le pillage de tombes est devenu
pratique courante dans la société
péruvienne archéologues doivent être
plus rapide que les pillards en
archéologues péruviens exprime sa
surprise en apprenant qu'on a trouvé des
objets en or il est rare que les
archéologues trouve des objets en or
avant que les pillards ne s'en empare
durant les trois années de fouilles à
couteaux wazi pas une pièce n'a été volé
c'est étonnant étant donné que les
objets en or ont été trouvés
on organise sur le site une cérémonie
suivant en cela les conseils de
l'archéologue lui senida carriole
monsieur gâteau pourrait vous allumez
les cigarettes les cigarettes sont
offertes aux défunts le sénat était
inquiète pour le site la cérémonie
n'ayant pas pu avoir lieu l'année
précédente
l'alcool de sucre de canne est offert
aux morts les participants doivent aussi
la zone où quelques gouttes
je fais partie de ceux qui sont nés ici
dans les angles nous commettons un
blasphème envers les morts je leur
demande donc pardon mais cela peut
sembler bizarre mais j'explique aux
morts que nos recherches servent à la
science que faire à présent des trésors
plusieurs assemblées ont lieu nous ne
voulions pas que les objets restent au
village c'était trop risqué
il aurait été facile de venir avec un
fusil et de les voler pas question donc
de les laisser là bas c'était aux
villageois de se rendre à l'évidence ce
n'était pas à nous de dire vous n'êtes
pas compétents
cela aurait pu les offenser les offenser
gravement ces gens là ont toujours été
méprisé
nous devions éviter que cela recommence
les troubles ont éclaté dans tout les
andes
on ne peut pas leur dire on ne peut pas
vous confier ces objets l'état va s'en
charger pour vous c'est le discours que
tiennent les autorités aux villageois
c'est partout la même chose il a joué à
savent tout cela mais il n'apprécie pas
que quelqu'un de l'extérieur leur dise
il y avait un vrai dilemme
j'espérais que les villageois finirait
par se dire qu'ils n'étaient pas
capables de garder les objets que les
gardes et n'était pas la meilleure
solution
nous répétions sans cesse que ces objets
étaient important non seulement pour le
village mais aussi pour le pays et même
pour le monde pour notre civilisation
les journaux nous ont relayés en disant
que ces pièces étaient uniques ont
répété aux villageois la même chose
chacun a réfléchi et est arrivé à la
conclusion que nous avions peut-être
raison
ils savaient ce qu'il leur restait à
faire
[Musique]
il refuse de remettre les objets à
l'institut du patrimoine de lima mais
d'un autre côté ils ne veulent pas que
les trésors reste au village le docteur
emmett une suggestion organisons une
exposition au japon afin de récolter des
fonds
avec cet argent on construira un musée
au village qui abritera les objets
sa suggestion est acceptée à l'unanimité
beaucoup cependant restent sceptiques
j'ai cru qu'on ne reverrait jamais nos
trésors
quand on les a emmenés j'ai ressenti une
grande perte vous savez avec le temps
bien des choses changent et les gens
finissent par oublier
je craignais de ne plus jamais les
revoir
j'avais peur que l'on nous ait trompé
les précieux objets quitte le village
le docteur elias au taquet cateau décide
d'avancer le calendrier
du lycée qui se retrouve seul
la suite est sans surprise l'assistant
du maire de san pablo arrive en trombe
escorté par la police ils m'ont demandé
où était parti monsieur au nook et s'il
avait emporté avec lui les objets de
valeur je n'ai pas eu beaucoup de temps
pour réfléchir mes collègues c'est parti
depuis une dizaine de minutes
la police aurait pu les rattraper
j'ai dit qu'ils aient fait partie depuis
une heure ils ont regardé leurs montres
et ont dit qu'ils allaient établir un
contact radio
à la mairie on nous avait dit que
l'équipe d'archéologues allait emporter
tous les objets découverts sur le site
de kourou asie sans autorisation
sans autorisation
ignorant ce qui est arrivé à leurs
collègues restés au village le docteur
elias ou ktk taux se présente à un
carrefour
la police nous sommes de s'arrêter nous
ne nous attendions pas à être interpellé
à cet endroit
je ne pensais pas que nous aurions des
problèmes quand la police nous a demandé
de nous arrêter j'ai compris que j'avais
sous-estimé la situation
[Musique]
le docteur montre la lettre pour
l'institut du patrimoine à lima que
l'équipe a écrite la nuit précédente
elle stipule que les objets de valeur
doivent rejoindre lima la police accepte
ce justificatif
mais insiste tout de même pour les
accompagner
il s'agit soit disant de les escorter
mais cela lui permet aussi de les
surveiller
durant tout le voyage vers cage à marca
l'officier de police ne dit pas un mot
arrivé à cajarc à un autre problème les
attend la responsable leur ordonne de
lui remettre les objets en or
journalistes sont là les chercheurs
doivent remettre les objets il faut
juste attendre que la chef de la police
revienne de déjeuner
le docteur se précipitent pour
téléphoner directement à l'institut du
patrimoine à lima
l'instabilité politique du pays
perturbent les télécommunications
et puis quelqu'un décrochera-t-il il
joue là sa dernière carte c'est un
miracle que quelqu'un ait décroché
j'ai parlé directement au ministre kim a
affirmé ne pas avoir donné l'ordre
d'amener les objets à cage à marca il a
promis d'appeler l'institut du
patrimoine à cajamarca et de leur
demander d'autoriser les archéologues a
amené les objets à lima je n'en revenais
pas
ils l'ont échappé belle les trésors de
kourou asie y compris les objets en or
sont en chemin pour lima ils ne
reverront pas de sitôt leur région
natale
[Musique]
ils ont à mons pas les favoris l'ont
démontré sa volonté
[Musique]
m
mariani
[Musique]
m
après être resté un an à lima les
trésors de couteau oasis ont prêté au
japon
à partir de 1992 les archéologues
organise douze expositions à travers le
pays
les expositions accueille deux cent
mille visiteurs grâce aux fonds récoltés
le projet de construction du musée se
concrétise
en 1994 on commence à faire des copies
les spécialistes en métallurgie viennent
d'apporter leur aide
bien que ce ne soit que des répliques on
utilise de l'or
pour rester proches des originaux on
ajoute 10 % d'argent les originaux
portent des marques causés lors de leur
enfouissement même ses imperfections
sont reproduites
le matériel est très délicat si un
accident arrive il faut refondre tout le
métal il faut six mois à trois
spécialistes pour produire 8 magnifique
réplique
en 1994 alors que ses collègues
travaillent sur les copies le docteur se
rend à la conga le musée du village qui
ne semblait qu'un rêve va devenir
réalité
une organisation est née afin de
promouvoir la culture l'association
culturel de kourou asie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
l'hymne de péruviens retenti au dessus
du chantier du musée creuser ici on
trace au sol un carré qui va être le
centre d'une cérémonie
monsieur nous qui doit briser puis
enterré une bouteille d'alcool de cannes
[Musique]
il disait qu'on ne reverrait jamais les
trésors
je leur ai dit qu'ils se trompaient tous
ils n'ont pas voulu me croire
ils disaient ces gens là nous ont volé
nos trésors
pour la construction du musée on a fait
appel à un architecte de cages à marca
d'une surface de 300 mètres carrés il
sera en béton et en acier
ce sera un bâtiment splendide qui
éblouira les villageois le budget global
s'élève à 20 millions de yens on compte
produire de l'électricité localement
même si la lumière naturelle sera le
plus souvent utilisés on n'installe pas
de système d'alarmé si le docteur
voulait des copies ce qu'il aurait été
trop risqué d'exposer des originaux
[Musique]
ce que les archéologues ramène au
village en octobre 1994
c'est en fait une paire de copies ainsi
que les origines la faire c'est réglé
sans effort ou le docteur at il puisé
d'énergie nécessaire à ce travail
je suis un amoureux des andes le paysage
les gens tout cela m'enchante
je voudrais donc faire quelque chose
pour cet endroit c'est par amour pour
cette région
si les gens du coin sont satisfaits de
mon travail
pourquoi ne pas faire quelque chose pour
eux
[Musique]
depuis 35 ans yoshi ono qui se consacre
à l'étude de la région des andes
[Musique]
son épouse de la deuxième génération des
japonais installés au pérou
le travail est loin d'être achevée il
faut expliquer aux villageois la raison
des copies à l'institut du patrimoine à
lima je vous conseille de conserver les
originaux en dehors du musée de façon à
ne tenter personne de mal intentionné
les villageois hésite encore ils ne sont
pas satisfaits des copies mais craignent
pour la sécurité des origines au seuil
annoncé il ya quelques devons-nous faire
garder les trésors ici où les entreposer
ailleurs devons nous exposer les copies
ou les originaux que faire
les archéologues ouvre le musée avant
son inauguration afin de permettre aux
villageois de voir les copies
originaux et copies sont placés côte à
côte sans aucune indication
chacun essaye de distinguer les vrais
des faux
à
les habitants de san pablo on vend de
cette avant-première et se rendre au
village
elles sont magnifiques les copies ont dû
demander bien du travail impossible de
distinguer les unes des autres
je pensais qu'il y aurait beaucoup de
différences entre les deux et j'ai eu
beau les regarder pas moyen de les
distinguer
comme promis les trésors en or sont
retournés au village villageois donnent
leur accord pour que les copies soit
seul exposé au musée
le jour de l'inauguration arrive enfin
le groupe de surveillance est arrivée
l'ancien maire de san pablo est
également présent
d'anciens collègues de l'équipe de
fouilles sont là
l'hélicoptère du président fujimori sur
le point d'atterrir
cette dernière nouvelle se répand et la
foule se presse sur la colline le
docteur accueille le président
[Musique]
six mois seulement après le début des
travaux l'hymne de péruviens retentit à
nouveau
[Musique]
les archéologues font don du musée
village les officiels du village
président est au retour au pays des
trésors ce musée a vu le jour grâce à la
coopération entre le peuple péruvien et
nos amis japonais
je déclare le musée ouvert
le trésor de coudre ou asie attire
aujourd'hui bien du monde
l'équipe des archéologues offert les
copies à l'association culturelle du
village
le ministre de la culture a autorisé les
villageois à vendre les objets des
fouilles
excepté sur nous
tout semble s'être arrangé le dieu de la
sphère est dénouée
les archéologues compte apaiser les
tensions
beaucoup de bruit pour rien mais tout se
finit bien
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard archéologues
reprenez les foules
[Musique]
oui
il
[Musique]